uh
yep we're still talking about collagen
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be revisiting dermatologist dr
dre and discussing some of her advice on
the worst foods for collagen production
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor build bar
so whenever i'm in like a meal or a
snack rut
one of my go-to's for just like my
little protein fix is definitely one of
these bars honestly there are so many
really delicious flavors and the texture
is really unlike any other protein bar
they actually taste more like a
chocolate bar
the flavor of the day
oh fresh box
i'm going for my favorite cookies and
cream if you know
you know
that these ones are totally amazing
so much chocolate mmm
i gotta make sure i don't have it
all over my face
oh
she's good so these are a lower sugar
bar so i usually like to pair them with
a source of carbs and fat for my hunger
crushing combo so for example like a
piece of fruit with some almond butter
is a really great option but if you want
to give them a try yourself check out my
link in the description and use my promo
code abby15 to get 15 off of your order
now before we get into it feel free to
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always please
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are new here
welcome please subscribe to the channel
and ring that bell so that you never
miss out on an episode okay so for
starters dr dre is really no stranger to
the channel as we've previously
discussed her low-fat high-volume vegan
diet in my video right here
but today we're going to be focusing on
her skin health diet advice specifically
as it relates to wellness culture's
current sweetheart collagen
now first of all i do have a whole blog
post on collagen for skin health which
i'm going to link below
but to refresh
collagen is a protein that provides
structure and support for our bones skin
muscles and hair and of course our
levels do decline as we age resulting in
visible signs of aging like wrinkles
now i want to preface this video by
saying i'm not a dermatologist and i
wholeheartedly respect the expertise of
clinicians like dr dre
but this is definitely an area where our
skills and our expertise do overlap so i
do think it's nice to hear another
perspective so let's dive in there are
two ways our diet impacts uh glycation
of collagen first of all increases in
blood sugar and you can actually be
ingesting advanced glycation and
products that do in fact localize to the
skin and further contribute to
this cross-linking of collagen and skin
aging research does suggest that
advanced glycation end products
otherwise known as ages can cause
oxidative stress and inflammation in the
body
ages are either naturally present in
foods or they're formed with foods that
are rich in protein and fat are cooked
at a very high temperature so for
example like grilling a t-bone steak
i'm going to consume all of this at the
same time because i am a free american
now it's important to note that one
piece of meat isn't going to overload
your body with ages and age you 20 years
rather toxins like ages tend to
accumulate over time and will also
depend on the rest of your diet and
other lifestyle habits so for example we
know that antioxidant-rich foods have
been shown to help mitigate the effects
of ages on the body which means that
dyes that are rich in things like fruits
and vegetables will often be lower in
ages before i get into the list of foods
that are more problematic for the health
of the collagen in your skin i want to
emphasize that i am not telling you guys
that these foods are off limits and that
you should completely cut them out of
your diet i really appreciate this
disclosure as i have to admit i'm a bit
weary of any kind of like bad food lists
especially after kind of the food
demonizing and fear-mongering that i
heard in the video that i reviewed on
her a while back now i also want to flag
that while i obviously am a dietitian
because i love helping people improve
their lives through food for most people
cutting out a few random foods isn't
going to have a significant impact on
something like your skin if you're still
engaging in other skin harming
activities like smoking drinking in
excess sun exposure excess stress etc
and actually dr dre does say this
herself in another one of her videos
right here but anyways let's get to her
list number one donuts donuts can be
problematic for the health of the
collagen in your skin as well as
throughout the rest of your body because
they're very very high in sugar and so
when you eat donuts your blood sugar can
spike quite a bit okay so in this clip
dr dre is suggesting that the reason
donuts are on the no-no list are because
a they're high in sugar and low in fiber
and b they're deep fried so starting
with reason number one
if we actually compare a donut with one
medium sweet potato which is typically
regarded as like a healthy complex carb
we are actually looking at arguably
comparable amounts of sugar depending on
the size of your sweet potato and while
sweet potato sugar is naturally
occurring and bound up with fiber which
is really important for blood sugar
regulation
sweet potatoes actually have a slightly
higher glycemic load than a donut
confusing i know
but this is where the cooking method
also comes into play because that
cooking method can also drive up those
ages
now because they're fried at a high heat
donuts actually have seven times the
amount of ages than a roasted sweet
potato so yeah donuts are probably not
the best food for our skin especially
because sweet potatoes also have lots of
vitamin c and other antioxidants to help
mediate that aga burden but honestly i
kind of hate these buzzfeed style
listicles and i find them really
problematic because there are just so
many nuanced factors at play and there
are always going to be random outliers
that really don't make a whole lot of
sense
so for example dried fakes have almost
twice the ages as a donut would have so
you know eating food just becomes way
more complicated than needs be and i
think that we need to look at the bigger
picture when it comes to nutrition
guidelines rather than you know
demonizing specific foods but i'm going
to get to some more alternative more
simplified messages in a little bit
let's see what else is on our list
number two white bread
white bread has almost no fiber and it's
a refined carbohydrate can lead to quite
an uptick in your blood sugar again when
we reduce food down to kind of meal
components or ingredient components we
kind of miss the bigger picture on our
health and sure a high fiber high
protein bread is better for blood sugar
regulation and is lower on the glycemic
index but we often do not eat bread in
isolation
it's usually a vehicle for other things
like veggies meats and spreads which are
all opportunities to add in extra fiber
protein and healthy fats aka the hunger
crushing combo
not to mention even something like white
wonder bread
contains about 2 grams of fiber and 6
grams of protein i say if you honestly
truly prefer white bread over whole
grain
fine go for it but i say dress up those
naked carbs and make them hunger
crushing combos as that alone will help
to modulate the overall glycemic load
putting barbecue sauce on meat and
cooking the meat in barbecue sauce at
high heat is really amplifying the
content of advanced glycation and
products not to mention barbecue sauce
have a high amount of added sugar the
added sugar
plus
the high heat cooking of the meats
further increases the overall age
content of the meat first of all i just
gotta ask how much barbecue sauce are we
eating it's too much
excuse me it's too much because if you
need to coat your meat and sauce
you're probably not doing barbecue right
but anyways she is correct that like a
grilled barbecue steak will contain more
ages than one that is stewed for example
and that the caramelization of sugars
via what we call the mylard reaction
does also seem to amplify this result
and while barbecue sauce is rich in
sugar it actually has a relatively low
glycemic load when we consume it with
foods as
i don't know
we usually do
throw in some antioxidant rich veggies
on the grill as well and you know your
barbecue dinner doesn't look so
dangerous after all
now if flavor is a concern instead of
using a ton of sauce you can try adding
a meat marinade before you cook
so research suggests that marinating
your meat for one hour helps to reduce
those ages by half which is actually a
tip that she gives as well later on in
this video any kind of mixed drink
cocktail these are a double hitter
because alcohol on its own
is not very good for the health of your
skin it's very inflammatory and then you
have in the cocktail a lot of sugars i
specify sugary because i'm not actually
sure
about diet soda in this case now we
already know that anything in excess
including alcohol and high sugar sodas
are not so great for the body in general
never mind just the skin
so limiting your alcohol intake to less
than 10 drinks a week
is what i would say
good practice just for overall health
as for her mention of research linking
booze to more visible signs of aging
i think it makes absolute sense that a
toxin like alcohol might not be great
for your skin
but i will just say that this study she
mentions showed us just an association
and there are a lot of confounding
variables here like the fact that
drinkers may be more likely to smoke may
have more stress in their lives maybe of
lower socioeconomic status etc so it's
really not as simple and alarming as you
know one glass of wine adds x number of
years to your skin package chips cookies
and crackers these have a pretty
substantial amount of advanced glycation
and products at baseline because of the
way they are prepared and oftentimes
they have substantial added sugar okay
so refined processed foods are generally
higher on the glycemic index but they're
not all created equal so for example
doritos chips have significantly less
age than sun chips why
i don't know i'm not really sure but
what i'm saying is that that information
isn't very intuitive or readily
available on a package
and i also want to flag that we don't
even have a safe established level for
age intake
i did find one study suggesting that
fifteen thousand kilo units of ages
daily would be considered a high age
diet
so if we use that as a guide consuming a
classic package snack like three oreos
aka 530 kilo units of ages
seems pretty benign i don't think we
need to be alarmist about it and i
actually don't think that she is either
hot dogs pepperoni and bacon these are
some of the worst meats that you can
consume for the health of your skin they
are incredibly high in advanced
glycation and products if you eat a hot
dog on white bread you put barbecue
sauce on it that is a set up for not
being so good for your skin so like i
said before
we don't eat these foods in isolation so
even with foods considered the worst for
ag content like bacon and hot dogs and
pepperoni the dose makes the poison as
does the cooking method what it's served
with and the rest of your diet so for
example a strip of bacon has 10 times as
many ages when fried versus when
microwaved and pairing your hot dog with
some veggies like she said can also help
to offset that he burden eating a
balanced diet that has foods from all
food groups healthy fats avocado
monounsaturated fats can help to
minimize the spike in blood sugar and
fruits and vegetables are packed with
antioxidants that are really beneficial
to the integrity of your collagen and
for reducing the burden of oxidative
stress that comes from environmental
exposures that damage your collagen
absolutely this is why i always say i
like to focus on what we can add to our
meals rather than what we have to take
away so i really do appreciate that dr
dre is emphasizing how we can optimize
high age foods without needing to
completely eliminate them from the diet
then your eating order can help as well
specifically front loading protein
earlier
in your eating as opposed to waking up
first thing in the morning and eating a
sugary donut so if you're gonna have a
donut in the morning maybe have some
protein beforehand or along with it to
kind of help minimize that sugar spike
so yeah she is talking about the hunger
crushing combo about dressing up those
naked cars with a source of fiber
protein and healthy fats and i love that
so research does suggest that food order
may in fact impact our blood sugar
levels so for example one small study
found that eating protein or veggies
before carbs helped to lower post meal
blood sugar spikes in individuals with
diabetes now we don't have a whole lot
of research on how that translates to
healthy individuals but i would say in
general we know that adding that protein
in there can definitely help but
consuming vinegar with a meal is another
way to lessen the burden of advanced
glycation and product that are formed in
glycation okay so if dr dre wants to
send me some info on this i would love
to see it because i looked hard
and i couldn't find any research
explaining why having vinegar with your
meal or your food would reduce age
load only of course that marinating your
meat before cooking could help so i can
see the connection there but um i don't
have actual evidence suggesting that you
need to take like a shot of vinegar an
acid based marinade marinating your meat
in either lemon juice or vinegar before
cooking can ultimately reduce the
total amount of ages
yep agreed we already chatted about that
rather than broil roast fry
instead steam boil or poach
or stew your meats incorporate spices
into your cooking of these foods
cinnamon garlic ginger and cumin are all
spices totally so one of the easiest
ways to lower the formation of age ease
is to decrease the cook time and the
temperature as cooking with moist heat
like poaching steaming and stewing more
often can definitely help so for example
poached chicken has less than a fourth
of the ages of roasted chicken
now again i want to zoom out a bit
because we're kind of obsessing over
minute meat cookery details and also
losing sight of the fact that our bodies
naturally produce collagen in-house from
the protein that we get from foods
including meat so on the one hand we may
be ingesting ages by cooking our meat at
high cooking temperatures we're also
getting some collagen promoting protein
as well
and if we balance out the meal with
vitamin c rich vegetables antioxidants
and fiber
we can actually create a generally skin
healthy meal
even in the presence of some ages so i'm
not disagreeing with her i actually
agree with her on most friends here if
not all but i'm just saying we kind of
don't need to obsess over it oh my god
okay it's happening everybody stay calm
everyone try incorporating green tea or
white tea into your diet as a beverage
green tea and yt both have antique
glycation effects studies have found
that plant phenols found in certain
spices and tea can help to lower the
effects of ages especially actually
turmeric which she didn't mention thanks
to its compound curcumin now green tea
also contains the antioxidant quercetin
which has been shown to help hinder age
formation and is also found in other
plant-based foods like grapes apples
tomatoes cherries and bell peppers so
when we eat a really colorful diet we're
able to get a lot of these benefits
without needing to be so obsessive about
it if you eat a balanced diet you're
going to have many beneficial things
coming in that overall help buffer some
of the blood sugar spikes and glycation
overall yes yes yes
yes
yes
yes it's all about how can we add some
other nutritious foods in to help
mitigate some of the effects of some of
the more processed higher age foods i
want to just summarize this all up for
you guys
i would say that the majority of dr
dre's recommendations aren't really
novel or sensationalized and they align
really nicely with the dietary
recommendations that we are already well
aware of like you know eating in
moderation portion control and eating a
varied and balanced diet that
prioritizes fruits and vegetables so i
love that and if you're already doing
these things i really don't think
there's any reason to freak out about
having an occasional donut or hot dog
and as dr dre actually says herself in
this video
we're here to live not just to follow
rules and i wholeheartedly agree
now one thing i didn't hear her
explicitly mention is the benefit of
adding more vitamin c rich foods to your
meals which can also help to hinder age
formation promote collagen production in
the body and provide antioxidants
also i really don't think you need to
stress at all about the minutia of
cookery when it comes to plant-based
foods because research suggests that
levels of ages are even lower in things
like fruits vegetables and whole grains
after they've been cooked so eat a
variety and eat them however you like if
we want to make the info in this video
which i think is largely quite great by
the way but if we want to make it a
little bit more accessible and practical
and simple for the viewer
here's what i think you need to know
one focus on eating a variety of
colorful fruits and vegetables and
prioritize plant-based proteins over
higher fat animal proteins more often
two if you do enjoy higher fat animal
proteins try to cook them low and slow
using a wet cooking method if possible
and then pair them with lots of colorful
produce three enjoy sweet foods in
moderation and pair them with a source
of fiber protein and or healthy fats aka
the hunger crushing combo
and four
flavor foods with marinades spices and
herbs and try to rely a little less on
sugary sauces or glazes folks i think we
gave a lot more information than
necessary here about all these scary age
compounds but all i think you really
need to think about here is variety and
like dr dre says herself moderation
focus on what we can add to reduce the
age content of a meal and acknowledge
that diet is really just one small piece
of the puzzle when it comes to our skin
i think both dr dre and i would both
rather see everyone religiously wear
sunscreen then swear off donuts and
cocktails for life
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thank you again to
billbar for sponsoring this video if you
liked it be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next subscribe to
the channel
you